[Musique]
bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro du 78
weekend tout de suite le sommaire de ce
vendredi 13 mai Lundi 9 Mai eu lieu la
réouverture définitive de la galerie des
carrosses du château de Versailles fermé
au public depuis 2007 la galerie a
rouvert ses portes grâce au messena de
la Fondation d'entreprise Michelin
Claude grajon membre de l'organisation
du festival cajin et zidco est en
plateau pour nous présenter la 4e
édition de ce festival un festival sur
joir Pontchartrain du 13 au 15 mai pour
faire découvrir la musique de la
Louisiane et ce weekend venez découvrir
la réserve naturelle de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline en plus des portes ouvertes les
guides de la réserve organisent une
grande randonnée pour découvrir le
patrimoine de l'île de loisir à travers
sa faune sa flore et une touche
d'histoire
des lundi 9 mai a eu lieu la réouverture
de la galerie des carrosse du château de
Versailles fermé au public depuis 2007
celle-ci a pu rouvrir ses portes grâce
au messénat de la Fondation d'entreprise
Michelin pour l'occasion toutes les
voitures ont été
restaurées il est le joyau de la
collection exposée dans les grandes
écuries du château de Versailles il
s'agit du carrosse du sacre de Charles X
4 tonnes 5 M de haut 7 m de long cette
voiture est reconnue comme le
chef-dœuvre de la carrosserie française
pour l'ingéniosité de sa mécanique la
richesse de ses ors et des ornements
auquels concourent tous les arts
décoratifs le carrosse dans la monarchie
française c'est le symbole du pouvoir
hein du pouvoir en marche et à versaill
et bien nous n'avons pas des véhicules
pour voyager hein nous n'avons des
véhicules pour montrer le roi donc il
faut bien comprendre que le carrosse
c'est comme un trône ambulant et trône
c'est-à-dire aussi un objet d'art euh
réalisé par les meilleurs artistes et
artisans de de la couronne fermé au
public depuis 2007 la galerie des
carrosses vient de rouvrir grâce au
messena de la Fondation Michelin la
surface d'exposition a doublé et s'étend
à présent sur plus de 1000 mètres carrés
elle présente l'une des plus importantes
collection de carrosses d'Europe
entièrement restaurées différents films
fait à partir d'images de drone et de
captation 3D à l'intérieur des carrosses
permettent de comprendre l'apparition de
ces voitures et la technique utilisée
pour les fabriquer l'appareil
pédagogique est effectivement très
important pour le public parce que
finalement c'est des collections un peu
insolites donc il faut expliquer au
public d'abord et bien pourquoi ce sont
des objets d'histoire ici chaque Caroche
c'est une page de l'histoire de France
et puis les faire aussi un peu rentrer
et bien dans dans cette technique
hippomobile du char funèbre de Louis XVI
aux voitures de la présidence en passant
par les berlines du mariage de Napoléon
1er les carrosses de Versailles sont des
monuments historiques et artistiques à
l'image des écuries royales bâtis par
Jules ardois Mansard entre
1679 et
1682 et une autre exposition est
également pour votre weekend sur
Versailles au carré à la farine jusqu'au
15 mai une exposition pour rendre
hommage au peintre Vincent Casa et sa
famille on peut retrouver des œuvres de
son oncle Jean Rigot peintre de la
Marine de son grand-père Pierre Gaston
Rigot peintre post impressionniste des
dessins de béd de son célèbre frère
Philippe Casa et de son père André Casa
anciennement caricaturiste pour la Une
de l'équipe
et tout de suite place à notre première
invité Claude grjant bonsoir bonsoir
alors Claude vous venez nous parler
aujourd'hui de la 4e édition du festival
que vous organisez cajin et zidco sur
Joire Pontchartrin donc ça démarre ce
soir et ça se poursuit jusqu'à dimanche
on va revenir un peu sur les origines de
ce festival expliquez-nous son histoire
alors son histoire
c'est l'histoire de joir Pontchartrin en
fait puisque Jérôme Philippo qui
était ministre de Louis XIV en charge de
la
Louisiane a eu son nom disons rendu
célèbre par il a été donné au lac qui
borde la nouvelle-orléand qui s'appelle
le lac Pontchartrin donc tout le monde a
entendu parler de la la catastrophe
Caterina donc c'est le lac Pontchartrin
qui a débordé sur la nouvelle léant et
donc cela qui avait été euh baptisé au
nom du du ministre de l'époque
par le moine d'berville qui a découvert
l'embouchure du du Mississippi donc une
origine historique entre ces deux villes
enfin cette ville et cet état et de là
vous avez créé une association qui
s'appelle Topla voilà c'est-à-dire que
voilà Topla est une association qui est
en fait le comité de jumelage euh un
jumelage qui est actuellement
entre une ville qui s'appelle Hamond qui
est en fait au bord du lac
monontchartrain et et la ville de de de
de joir pour Chartrin donc vous avez eu
l'idée de créer un festival voilà et
donc après ce jumelage qui est à
l'origine en
1998 j'avais proposé à Madame le maire
de l'époque de créer un festival étant
donné que je suis dans cette mouvance et
que je je me je pensais pouvoir
rassembler beaucoup de monde venant de
d'Europe et et de France bien bien
entendu et donc le premier festival a eu
lieu en 2010 et donc il a lieu tous les
2 ans parce que c'est un travail
important il faut une équipe et c'est
très prenant
et quand on a fini d'organiser le
festival on est vraiment très tous très
fatigués voilà donc si tous les ans et
d'autant plus qu'il faut trouver des
moyens puisque actuellement si vous
voulez c'est un budget qui va qui
voisine les 45000 € et sans aucune
subvention à part le prêt du matériel
par la ville de pontchartterin mais
malheureusement il n'est pas possible
d'obtenir des des prêts à la fois du
département ou de la région parce que il
faut que le le festival a eu lieu déjà
depuis un certain nombre d'éditions
temps alors c'est un festival notamment
important car il y en a que deux qui
célèbrent la culture de la Louisiane en
France donc vous en faites partie et
cette année vous avez opté pour un
invité très spécial il s'agit de Gino de
la fosse alors vous allez nous en parler
mais juste avant on
l'écoute
en louisian on a la musique cajin et la
musique Zid la musique cajin a été
influencée par la musique country et
western et la musique Z a puisé ses
influences dans le
[Musique]
blu C de genres musicau sont joués à la
fois par les blancs et les
Noirs les instruments sont un peu
différents dans la musique à il y a de
l'accordéon de la guitare acoustique
alors que dans la mus peut trouver de
l'accordéon aussi mais aussi des
percussions de la basse et ça s'inspire
un peu plus du
[Musique]
BLU il a davantage
d'énergie ça n'empêche pas les musiciens
Z de jouer de la musique et
inversement dans tous les cas on s'amuse
bien
chez moi en louisian on était fermier et
on j de la musique après une grosse
journée de
travail ça n permett decompresser de
passer un bon moment jouer de la musique
chanter
danser c'est quelque chose que les gens
lis faisait pour se détendre avant
l'arrivée de la télévision et de la
radio par
exemple
la musique Z vient beaucoup du gospel et
prunte aussi quelques percussions des
Caraïbes avec les tambours
entreut c'est de là que notre musique
vient alors ma dernière venue en France
ça remonte à 2007 et j'ai joué pour un
gros festival c'est la prière fois que
je reviens dans votre pays depuis ce
temps je viens pour le festival à jouir
Pontchartrain et j'espère que beaucoup
de monde va venir on va jouer de la
musique zidco et cajin passer un bon
moment et on va faire en sorte même de
faire danser tout le
public j'aime beaucoup jouer de la
musique ici les Français aiment vraiment
ça ils aiment la musique ils dansent et
après beaucoup viennent en louisian et
écoutent de la musique queaj
zidco c'est super de se rencontrer et de
jouer pour eux les gens s'éclatent et
apprécient la musique notre style
traditionnel mais aussi plus
contemporain
parfois les Français aiment notre
musique et nos
artistes alors Gino de la fosse qu'on
vient d'entendre c'est une véritable
vedette en Louisienne pourquoi est-ce
que vous avez fait le choix de de cette
invité spéciale bien à chaque édition
évidemment nous renouvelons nous voulons
avoir un groupe nouveau et ça faisait
déjà quelques années que nous
souhaitions avoir Gino
mais ce musicien qui est très célèbre on
peut dire que actuellement c'est ZE V
d'ette là-bas quoi c'est c'est vraiment
le groupe qui est au sommet alors
au-delà de vouloir faire découvrir la
musique de la lusion vous cherchez
vraiment à partager toute la culture il
y a toute un une playéade de d'activités
d'actions culturel autour de la culture
vous investissez différents lieux
également ah oui bien bien sûr donc nous
allons avoir TR
éditions de film donc de cinéma où on va
projeter des des films qui parleent de
la Louisiane ou qui sont donc tournés
par des
louisianais pour pour faire découvrir
évidemment une autres aspect et nous
avons également des cours de cuisine de
de Louisiane et puis des cours
instrumentaux où on peut par faaire son
style cagin ail d'co soit pour la cord
ont la guitare ou le violon et et
donc voilà on on essaie de de de faire
connaître toute cette palette parce que
c'est c'est vraiment en Louisiane une
culture tout à fait différente de de
tout ce qu'il y a ailleurs aux
États-Unis quoi il y a il y a vraiment
cette présence française qui est encore
dans le cœur de tous les louisianis qui
ont résisté aux Anglais et et et on sent
toujours ce cette résistance aux Anglais
par la langue puisqueil y a encore en
gros
800000 cagin qui sont des locuteurs de
français et dont certains ont refusé de
parler l'anglais encore aujourd'hui
c'est c'est c'est quelque chose qui qui
est très émouvant c'est quand on quand
on va là-bas c'est c'est très émouvant
donc on pourra retrouver toute cette
culture on voyait bien que vous avez la
volonté de faire partager donc sur joir
Pontchartrain à partir de ce soir
vendredi 13 mai et jusqu'à dimanche 15
mai toutes les informations la
programmation les inscriptions pour les
différentes actions culturelles que vous
pourrez trouver sur le site à l'adresse
qui s'affiche à l'écran merci Claude
gragan d'être venu en plateau et de nous
avoir fait partager ce bel événement on
va à présent parler d'un autre festival
ce weekend qui va durer jusqu'au 22 mai
le festival mosaïque festival de musique
actuel au Mureau une programmation
éclectique pour cette 14e édition avec
de la saoule du blouse du rap du rock et
de la pop un événement qui se veut
convivial et
familial
dernier des
derniers petit pas petit pas dernier des
derniers pas pas
localisé ta
localis
et un rendez-vous pour les amoureux de
la nature à présent ce weekend c'est la
réserve naturelle de Saint-Quentin en
yeline qui ouvre ses portes et pour
l'occasion les guides du site naturel
organise une grande randonnée pour
découvrir le patrimoine de l'île des
loisirs on pourra découvrir ouvrir la
faune la flore et même une touche
d'histoire un reportage signé Mélanie
poket journée porte ouverte samedi à la
réserve naturelle mais pas seulement
pour la première fois le public pourra
faire une randonnée dans toute l'île de
loisirs quand vous venez visiter la
réserve naturelle je dirais vous êtes
dans le cœur de nature de l'île de
loisirs de Saint-Quentin en line de ce
territoire ça fait 30 ans maintenant
qu'on fait des expertises scientifiques
sur l'ensemble de l'île de loisir et la
nature exceptionnelle est bien sur
l'ensemble du pourtour et donc là l'idée
c'est de vous faire découvrir ce que
vous pensez connaître en fait 10 km de
parcours autour du bassin de l'île de
loisir puis de la réserve il y sera
question de Flore avec le Cabaret des
oiseaux une plante retenant l'eau de
pluie de faunes la base accueillant de
nombreuses espèces mais aussi de 300 ans
d'histoire on va vraiment élargir la
discussion sur le patrimoine naturel de
l'étand Saint-Quentin qui est inscrit
donc dans un patrimoine historique
puisqueen fait il appartient au réseau
des étants éigoles cet étant a été créé
par le roi Louis XIV l'inscription se
fait jusqu'à vendredi une vingtaine de
places est prévu pour découvrir ou
redécouvrir l'île de loisir qui
délivrera certainement un grand nombre
de
secret et on ouvre à présent une page
littérature comme chaque vendredi votre
rendez-vous avec la sélection littéraire
du pavé du canal aujourd'hui c'est
Pauline amier du pavé du canal qui vous
présente le Polard Condor de CARIF Ferré
alors je vais te présenter le nouveau
roman de Karil Ferret donc c'est encore
un polar cette fois-ci il s'appelle
Condor ça se passe au Chili il fait un
peu suite à son précédent roman qui
était mapoué qui se passait en Argentine
là on suit une jeune
Reporterre qui fait partie de
l'opposition chilienne qui est une
mapouchée donc qui a été opprimée
pendant pendant l'époque enfin don la
famille a été opprimée pendant l'époque
de Pinochet et là elle va enquêter dans
les quartiers très pauvres de du Chili
sur des des sombres histoires de drogue
et elle fait équipe avec un avocat qui
qui se dit lui-même avocat des causes
perdues voilà et tous les deux vont
partir sur une enquête qui évidemment va
mêler des gens très haut placés des
commerciaux et elle c'est une ancienne
journaliste non c'est non c'est une
étudiante en fait une étudiante en
journalisme les caméramanudord ok qui
s'associe avec un avocat s'associe avec
lui parce que en fait c'est un ami le
fils d'un ami àelle qui est tué qui un
jeune garçon qui n'avait aucun problème
qui faisait des études et cetera et le
meurtre est maquillé en overdose donc
elle y croit pas du tout elle fait appel
à ce à ce à cet avocat qui s'appelle
Esteban est-ce que c'est une continuité
dans tout ce qu'il a fait précédemment
ouais ouais alors il a beaucoup exploré
le continent sud-africain avec zouou
notamment il avait
exploré le la Nouvelle-Zélande avec sa
saga maori et là il s'intéresse beaucoup
plus plus à l'Amérique du Sud donc avec
mapoué puis maintenant Condor et à
chaque fois il part plus d'un an sur
place pour s'imprégner de la vie du pays
et de récolter le plus d'infos sur
l'histoire du pays donc une petitte
études sociaux avant au préalable pour
mener ses livre ou tout à
fait et pourquoi ne pas aller au cinéma
ce weekend cyil Hadad du cinéma Philippe
noir des clés sous boois vous présente
Mony Monster un film de jod Foster avec
Julien Robert et George
cl cette semaine notre coup de cœur est
le film mononey Monster réalisé par jod
Foster avec George croney et Julia
Robert L Gates est une personnalité
influente de la télévision et un gourou
de la finance à Wall Street les choses
se gâ lorsque Kyle un spectateur ayant
perdu tout son argent en suivant les
conseils de Gates décide de le prendre
en otage pendant son émission devant des
millions de
téléspectateurs monone Monster est le 4è
long métrage de l'actrice réalisatrice
Foster elle orchestre les retrouvailles
entre Jul Robert et George cl 12 ans
après Ocean 12es c'est également la 4è
collaboration entre les deux acteurs
principaux ce thriller sera à n'en pas
douter un des moments attendus du 69e
festival de Cann puisque le film est
présenté hors compétition avec à la clé
un moment fort de l'histoire du festival
car il s'agira de la toute première
visite canoise de l'héroïne de Pretty
Woman Mony Monster est proposé en
version originale et en version
française et estc IR cette semaine en
sortie nationale à l'espace Philippe
Noiré et viennent de nous rejoindre en
plateau Claude chose bonjour bonjour
Alors on le rappelle vous êtes donc le
président de l'Union régional 16 de
l'Île-de-France ouest de photographie et
aujourd'hui vous êtes accompagné de
Gérard moulin bonjour bonjour Vous êtes
artiste photographe et on va découvrir
que vous avez une spécialité presque on
peut dire Claude expliquez-nous pourquoi
est-ce queaujourd'hui ui vous venez nous
présenter Gérard moulin alors Gérard
moulin c'est quelqu'un que je connais
depuis fort longtemps Gérard est
quelqu'un qui qui fait la photo je crois
depuis bien des années il a fait partie
d'un d'un groupe de photographes les
3040 disons que les plus anciens de de
votre région sauront certainement de
quoi il s'agit où il y avait des des
têtes de la photographie donc Gérard est
un personnage est un homme qui a une
grande culture photographique
c'est-à-dire qu'on peut lui parler de de
de plein de gens il il aura toujours un
rappel vers un auteur particulier et
puis Gérard est aussi un un homme qui ne
fait que du noir et blanc que ça soit
argentique ou numérique parce que depuis
peu de temps et ben il est passé aussi
au numérique si vous voulez donc alors
on va en parler justement Gérard m je
disais on peut dire que il s'agit de
votre spécialité le noir et blanc
pourquoi est-ce que vraiment vous êtes
resté on peut dire encore au noir et
blanc alors je ne suis pas resté au noir
et blanc parce que j'ai
essayé pendant une courte période de 9
mois de faire de la couleur et je me
suis rendu compte que pour moi le
langage de la couleur ne correspondait
pas à mes attentes alors que le noir et
blanc de par la distance que ça prend
vis-à-vis de la réalité puisque notre
grand adversaire pour nous photographes
c'est quand même la réalité à partir de
cette réalité on doit faire autre chose
et le noir et blanc est un des moyens
qui permet qui qui permettent de faire
autre chose c'est-à-dire ne pas montrer
véritablement ce que c'est mais les
esprit de ce que l'on veut montrer et du
coup comment est-ce que vous réussissez
à à mettre en lumière l'esprit de ce que
vous cherchez à montrer et bien c'est
par la distance on n'est plus dans le
rapport à un sujet que l'on voit parce
que le photographe par nature
photographie ce qu'il voit et s'il ne
fait que montrer sur sa photographie ce
qu'il a vu ça n'a aucune importance
puisque c'est un constat et le constat
n'est pas en tout cas ce qui me concerne
moi je préfère montrer un peu ce qui
n'est pas visible dans les choses c'est
pour ça que mes photos portent
quand ce sont des personnages souvent
ils sont assez éloignés quand ce sont
des choses et des objets ils sont pris
avec beaucoup d'ombres beaucoup de
sombre et seulement des traces de
lumière et ce sont ces traces qui
m'intéressent particulièrement le
travail du noir et blanc relève pour
vous d'une démarche plus artistique que
la couleur non il y a des photographes
qui sont des coloristes et il y a des
photographes qui ne sont pas des
coloristes moi je me case dans la dans
la deuxè
parti des gens savent traiter la couleur
surtout que dans ma génération les
photographes étaient essentiellement des
noirs et blantistes dans puisque les
soit les écoles de photographie soit les
lieux où on échangeait sur la photo
était très peu porté était très peu
porté sur la couleur Claude quel rapport
vous entretenez vous avec le noir et
blanc bien disons que je rejoins ce que
vient de dire Gérard sur
l'essentiel vous savez que j'ai fait une
série sur versaill en noir et blanc et
je pense que la couleur dans ce cadre là
n'aurait rien amené souvent si vous
voulez comme la la sous-entendu Gérard
la couleur va peut-être distraire le le
les regardants au détriment si vous
voulez de l'essentiel qu'il y a dans la
photo c'est un peu comme ça que je
conçois moi aussi le noir et blanc
c'est-à-dire que quand on veut
concentrer vraiment le regard sur ce qui
est important dans la photo regardez
quand même tout ce que les grands
auteurs ont fait comme Willy Ronis
douano Isis enfin et je la la la liste
serait longue et comme l'a dit
Gérard il est vrai qu'à C à une époque
de la première moitié du 20e siècle la
couleur coûtait cher donc c'était aussi
un des critères mais ça ça disperse les
gens alors que il passe peut-être à côté
de l'essentiel et donc le noir et blanc
concentre les gens sur l'essentiel
est-ce que techniquement on aborde la
prise de vue le cadre un peu
différemment lorsqu'on ne fait que du
noir et blanc on voit pas les choses de
la même manière quand quand on est quand
on est coloriste on est tenu par la
nature et équilibre des couleurs qui se
présentent et savoir si on veut avoir
une dominante dans un sens ou dans un
autre tandis qu'en noir et blanc ce qui
compte c'est la lumière et les
contrastes et dans la mesure où on est
avec cette lumière et ces contrastes
déjà on peut mélanger beaucoup plus de
choses et les mettant les unes à côté
des autres ou et on n'est pas perturbé
ou quand on voit quand on voit une photo
couleur parce qu'il faut faire la
différence entre la photo couleur et la
photo en couleur la photo couleur c'est
de dire je vais quelque part je vois je
déclenche et puis ce qui est rouge et
rouge ce qui est bleu et bleu tandis que
dans la photo dans l'autre catégorie ce
sont tes photographes pour qui la
couleur a un sens et possède une
certaine détermination ils n'ont pas
l'utilisation de la couleur comme comme
élément secondaire mais l'élément
principal beaucoup de peintres
d'ailleurs avant les photographes
utilisaient la couleur non pas par la
couleur qui était en tant que telle mais
la couleur qui servait une idée qui
servit un projet une émotion on met pas
du bleu n'importe où on met pas du rouge
n'importe où il y a les différentes
sociétés européennes qui ont été marqué
par les différentes couleurs là je parle
des peintres et pour les photographes
les photographes qui sont dé coloristes
il y a beaucoup d'Italiens qui sont des
coloristes des grands il y a quelques
français mais pas
énormément il y a aussi des Australiens
qui ont beaucoup travaillé sur la
couleur mais pour moi c'est c'est pas
j'aime bien voir des photographies en
couleur quand elles me
conviennent moi je travaille en noir et
blanc essentiellement pour ça peut-être
sur le travail on vous disiez
l'argentique vous êtes passé au
numérique pourquoi aussi également
travailler sur le numérique alors je ne
suis pas passé au numérique je fais un
petit peu de photo numérique mais moi je
suis encore très attaché 80 90 % de mon
travail et de l'argentique parce que
j'ai je développe mes films j'ai la
nature sensuelle vis-à-vis e de l'objet
film et ce film ensuite j'ai mon
laboratoire je fais mes tirages moi-même
je j'ai accès à au à tout le à tout le
processus en couleur ce serait peut-être
plus compliqué mais enfin pour le noir
et blanc c'est quelque chose que je fais
depuis 1972 ou 73 donc je me sens bien
dans mon laboratoire parce que une fois
que le labo est fermé que la lumière
rouge apparaît et ben le temps n'existe
plus et le monde n'est plus le même que
celui que l'on a quand on n'y est pas
voilà j'aime encore toujours la
photographie argentique pour ça claud
chose vous vouliez nous parler d'une
exposition qui va démarrer demain à
Rambouillet oui c'est une exposition qui
est en cours à Rambouillet une
exposition sur la photographie nature
que je vous recommande particulièrement
c'est dans le chalet du parc animalier
de rambouiller donc sur la commune de
Clairefontaine c'est une souir son exact
ou un certain nombre de de de mes de mes
collègues photographes de de cette union
régionale du Sud-Ouest île- de-fance et
présente leurs photos jusque à la fin du
mois de mai donc n'hésitez pas à aller
voir ça c'est vous y verrez quelque
chose de très de très sympathique et des
photos en noir et blanc vous avez aussi
des il y a des photos en noir et blanc
mais il y a quand même beaucoup beaucoup
de couleurs donc voilà d'accord le le
message l'invitation est lancée clauduse
Gérard moulin merci d'être venu en
plateau et d'avoir répondu à nos
questions on vous retrouvera Claude très
certainement sur une autre rubrique
photographie et c'est déjà la fin de
cette émission je vous laisse la voir et
la revoir sur notre site internet il est
temps pour moi de vous souhaiter un
excellent
[Musique]
weekend